alright time for audience questions
submitted throughout the week by the
audience let me know what you want me to
address on the show first question is
hey David is Bernie's anti endorsement
list a good idea or will it backfire so
let me tell you what this is first
Bernie Sanders put out a list not of
people who have endorsed him but if
people who have said don't vote for
Bernie Sanders this is a list of a bunch
of prominent billionaires there are Wall
Street bankers on the list there are
some big corporate CEOs who have said
Bernie's a disaster don't vote Bernie
Bernie's policies are terrible so this
could be both that you know the question
is is it a good idea or will it backfire
it can both be a good idea that
backfires I mean that's sort of the idea
of a backfire which is something that is
a good idea ends up something ends up
not going as planned that ends up
actually being counterproductive so
there's a bunch of people on this list
that are relatively notable one that
comes to mind to me is billionaire
co-founder of Home Depot
Kenneth Langone who is a known big Trump
booster Disney CEO Bob Iger is on the
list JP Morgan Chase CEO Jamie Dimon is
on the list so the idea here is the
enemy of my enemy is my friend it's sort
of the idea here which is that if you
see or enemy of the of my enemy is my
friend
in Reverse sort of thing the idea being
if you see that a lot of these big
corporate multinational CEOs or whoever
don't like Bernie and you see the goals
of those same CEOs and billionaires as
not aligned with what you want you might
say the fact that these CEOs and Wall
Street bankers don't like Bernie
suggests to me that Bernie does have my
best interest in Bernie's in mind and
Bernie's policies would be what's best
for me and I am going to support Bernie
because these people don't like Bernie
it's a perfectly fine and reasonable
idea i I think that the risk is of being
couched as being against rich people and
this is also a thing where is it a badge
of honor or is it not a badge of honor
Joe Biden famously a couple of weeks ago
was caught saying to a group of big
donors listen I don't think we should
really hurt the
I don't think you're bad people I'm not
going after you
nothing is substantively going to change
for you if I become president of the
United States we're gonna deal with
something sort of around the edges and
that's going to be it Bernie's taking a
different approach bernie is saying oh
no I am going to change things for a lot
of these big corporate CEOs and for Wall
Street bankers he's outlined some of the
policies that would do that raising
taxes on the rich financial transactions
taxes that would eat away at some of the
Wall Street profits in order to take
that money and use it for useful social
programs and other kind of economically
stimulative spending and the idea is
that's good stuff
Bernie is saying things aren't going to
be so good for these corporate CEOs and
bankers that makes me like Bernie and
I'm going to vote for him now here's my
bottom line opinion on this I think it
doesn't matter okay
I don't think endorsements matter very
much and in the same way
I don't think anti endorsements very
very matter very much it's fine that
Bernie did this it's possible that it
will have some net positive benefit to
be perfectly frank I just don't think
many voters are either going to vote for
Bernie or not on the basis of whether
the home depot CEO likes Bernie or
doesn't like Bernie I just don't think
it matters I truly don't and there has
been over time more and more consensus
that endorsements really do not matter
that much other than there are some
really specific things that make a
difference sitting presidents going
around and saying I endorse X candidate
and they are who should take over for me
and I'm going to aggressively campaign
for them there is still the idea that
that matters didn't work out for Hillary
Clinton with Barack Obama but in general
there's the idea that that can make a
difference celebrity endorsements not
really moving the needle big political
endorsements doesn't really seem to make
much of a difference so I actually find
myself thinking that it's fine for
Bernie to do this there is a small
enclave of the electorate that may be
influenced by this big picture I don't
think it's gonna do much more haven't
before him one way or the other let me
know what you think if you disagree with
me if you think that Bernie's anti
endorsement list will move the needle in
some way could be for the better could
be for the worse let me know I
I hear from you